[Music]  it is easy to see vegas  is bouncing back as business booms  across the valley the demand for  entertainment  is also surging this week resorts world  announced that upcoming headliners  carrie underwood and celine dion have  added several additional show dates  for 2022 as they saw an extraordinary  amount of pre-sale ticket requests  these are just a few of many shows  debuting or coming back to the strip  and experts call it a sign our economy  is rebounding  the entertainers have a lot of people  that they actually  employ when they go back to work so the  sound stage the equipment people and all  of those folks  so it's a huge thing to just have  entertainers go back  and the people who support them some  shows returning this summer include  namesakes like cirque de soleil and the  blue man group